you
[Music]
welcome to cloud on air live webinars
from Google cloud we're hosting webinars
every Tuesday my name's Corey peal and
I'm joined by Priyanka Vergara is and
we're Google cloud customer engineers
we're going to talk about digital
transformation for non digital natives
today in our sea each at you may ask
questions at any time on the platform
and we have Googlers on standby to
answer them so let's get started alright
so companies often have some amount of
technical depth whether it's ditching
that old mainframe or its container
izing the applications so today we will
learn how non digital native companies
can actually start that process of
modernizing themselves ok I think we are
very we are way past this conversation
of why cloud but for the sake of
completeness I thought we'll go through
it and talk about a little bit in terms
of why cloud is important and why people
are looking into it so cloud offers
flexibility businesses today need to
scale the infrastructure based on their
demand and with cloud they're able to do
that as demands increase the cloud
infrastructure expands and as they
decrease the cloud infrastructure
automatically scales back down so that
is that is that flexibility is what
businesses need today and that's why
they're looking into cloud you actually
only pay for what you use and that's
another huge advantage of cloud you
reduce the capital expenditures when you
are trying to you know that that server
that you set up together or that
mainframe when you got it
it costs you a lot of money and you
realize later down that you may or may
not be using it enough so that is
capital or cost that you paid upfront
but without you don't have to do yeah
yeah exactly you do not have to worry
about the maintenance costs as well to
maintain those licenses to maintain the
underlying infrastructure all of that is
taken care of by the cloud
as well cloud providers increased it
basically increased this increases the
productivity of the employees so they
can be anywhere and can be working on
the infrastructure they don't have to
walk into the office to actually use the
infrastructure and that is the that is
huge beauty I think you wanna do yes yes
yes because when we have cloud so we
have our G suite in addition to Google
cloud platform and so a lot of the
collaboration and productivity I really
enjoy typing at the same time as
everyone else so you don't have to have
a meeting after the meeting to review
the notes and then plan again everything
is very productive exactly yeah everyone
can collaborate on the same document at
the same time and when it comes to cloud
your systems engineer and your
operations engineers can just you can
just log into the cloud console and the
portal and they can move things around
movie ends around and they don't have to
be in the data center to actually do
that so that's beautiful too
when you think about disaster recovery
and you have got like on-premise data
centers and you think about creating one
more data center for disaster recovery
you can imagine how much it could cost
so if you consider cloud for disaster
recovery you can basically spin up this
whole data center for disaster recovery
but you will not be paying for it until
the disaster actually happens so that's
again a huge advantage in terms of cost
and also resources it's also more much
more secure and the example I would take
here is somebody your employee could
lose a laptop which could lead into
losing software's that were on it and
keys that weren't on it but if you're
using cloud your laptop is just a medium
it's only getting used to get on to the
internet but not getting used to
actually get into your systems which is
yes and our hundreds of security
engineers and researchers definitely
helped so customers instead of trying to
provide that type of infrastructure
themselves and knowledge they can
leverage what we have exactly yeah and
then
lastly this is actually the biggest
point but I put it in the last because
you can't enjoy the benefits of
innovation and the technology and the
advancements in technology unless you've
actually made that leap and jump into
being in cloud you get closer to the
innovation you get closer to all the new
things that that the world is exploring
and you can try to when you are when you
are not in a silo on-premise yes that's
great innovation at scale is something
we can do when you do have cloud
available exactly alright so now that we
understand why we should move to cloud
let's consider the journey how do we get
there because today's audience is non
digital natives right so we're talking
about companies and financial sector
companies in our companies supporting
public sector government in general and
and those verticals have had a lot of
applications that were built prior and
we need modernization and move to cloud
so we're gonna focus a little bit more
on those types of use cases today and
for those in order to move to cloud here
are the four steps you migrate you bring
whatever it is that is old and legacy
into cloud so you can start to expand
and utilize it further and make it
modern while you do that you will at
some point get to a stage when you're in
hybrid or multi cloud mode so even if
you want to be multi cloud or hybrid
cloud or not you will be in that stage
some point in time because you will
either migrate one application or
migrate part of your application and
some of it will still stay where it is
for for some time so you'll deal with
that so we'll talk about the multi cloud
hybrid cloud strategy and then we'll
walk walk through how do you actually
start to modernize an application that's
been there for hundreds of years that's
very key for the audience that we are
speaking to today and then
and then talking about data and analysis
and what the ml is and what the what all
these buzzwords are and where do we
start in order to modernize ourselves
yeah so in this droney we have a lot of
unwraps and entry points and so some may
want to skip and just start developing a
new application and others are actually
going through this ordered process to
build that core foundation in order to
exploit the insights later on exactly
yes yeah so it's a journey for those who
are starting from something that's
traditional and if you already are cloud
native for example you're you started
with let's say containers you may be at
a point where you're ready to deal with
data and modernize and start doing your
mouth so you start right at step four so
it's up to you all right so we'll start
with migration CEOs know that moving to
cloud is is going to take a lot of money
and it's also going to take a lot of
time and most of the times they are
willing to invest in that but but when
you think about it in it leads to a
multi-month type project and a really
lot of upfront upfront planning and that
believe it or not save few if you think
about eight months project or moving to
cloud you lost the competitive descent
competitive advantages of actually
getting ahead of your competition well
you are going to in eight months but you
are all your resources are doing just
the project or moving to cloud so
believe it or not it is it is a process
that that you realize that you will be
spending a lot of time and money what if
what if you could actually start reaping
the benefits of cloud in the week in the
matter of weeks and three months yes
avoid spending a lot of money a lot of
resources and really get to execution
very soon very soon
exactly so here is how Google cloud can
help you do that and we have great
success stories and customer stories and
how we
have helped customers moving to cloud in
a matter of literally days and here's
how we do that this is the we have a
professional services organization where
we bring conversations from your
engineers to to our engineers so there's
a one-to-one engineer to engineer
conversation we start with something
called cloud start which is either one
to three days strategic engagement where
you actually sit with each other and
figure out what is it that you want to
migrate yeah what is the first project
that you want to do so we scope out the
goals with you in that time you could
pay you could you could decide how big
or small that is and depending on that
we could do one or three days and then
once we have that goal set we go into
this cloud cloud sprint which is really
a process in which we work with you for
weeks could be two weeks could be four
weeks depending on what you picked in
the cloud start phase the project that
you picked it could be a couple of weeks
and then in those weeks you've we
actually help you create the timeline
move from from your on-prem or your
other cloud into Google Cloud and bring
that workload in so we took some time to
actually decide what you want to do and
then whatever you pick we give you an in
cloud sprint we actually move you into
cloud with that workload and then
obviously that secure is optional it's a
two-day workshop for security risk and
compliance concerns and we make sure
that whatever design we deliver on in
sprint is actually secure be poor your
standards yes and so change management
is a big thing here because you have a
lot of operational changes and so
luckily in addition to some of these
services if we want to work with some of
our partners or professional services on
custom scope after some of these really
quick ones we're able to do that too so
it makes it really exciting but yes
change is something we can manage and
make it really easy
easy to get to cloud yeah and then we
have some tools that can help you do
that as well so we talked about the
professional services and the
hand-holding part of it and taking you
into cloud there are some tools that we
are for as well which can help you
either
you can self-serve with for example
cloud and your is the first one which
you could use to actually move your
migrate yourself your V virtual machines
into cloud there is it's literally when
you go into Google Cloud console and go
on VMs or a compute engine you'll see an
option to migrate of VM and you just
pull them in you can do it self-service
you could also work with cloud and your
hand in hand to set up a migration if
it's bigger or if you need help if
you're like I can't do this myself I
don't have the team to do it all of that
cloud into your will jump into help as
well from at that point you could also
work on disaster recovery workloads with
with cloud indoor so it's not just my
grading it's also making sure that if
you have a disaster if you need a
disaster recovery system you could set
up that as well touch on Velo strata a
little bit if you have VMware machines
that were virtual machines that you
would like to bring over into cloud we
just acquired a company called well a
strata and you could do similar to cloud
and or you could bring your VM instances
in virtual the VMware virtual machines
into cloud as well oh great
yes those of you who are on five five
for VMware definitely take note here
yeah and then the data transfer plans
any application you try to move is going
to have some component of data is going
to have it could be petabytes of data it
could be small amounts of data if you
have an Origin large amounts of data
that you want to move over we recommend
you use data transfer appliance which is
really a box that gets shipped to you
and then you load the data out from your
data center and then you ship it back to
us and then you see it all in the
console showing up magically oh that's
great there's a lot of time in those
migration projects where you calculate
the network bandwidth and realize it's
gonna take maybe four years four years
yeah so this is definitely a way to
speed up the process exactly yeah and
then there are some other tools if you
just want to move data from other cloud
into our cloud there are some online
tools as well that we offer transfer
services so here's what I was talking
about lush is a cosmetic company and
they are really it's an e-commerce
company they make they make handmade
cosmetic soaps and shampoos we were able
to bring them over into into Google
Cloud migrate their services into Google
cloud in 22 days it's great for a global
platform but actually yeah so that's why
I wanted to bring a story up just
because you could relate to it and that
speaks a lot about all the professional
services offerings that we discussed
right all right so with that second step
hybrid and multi cloud alright so I
talked with the infrastructure leads and
with the IT leads all the time and I
find that longer an enterprise has been
around the more complex their systems
start to get an infrastructure starts to
get over the years they've created
applications that are on-premise some
that are in other cloud some that are
SAS applications and all of those kind
of have to work together so it becomes
this huge mesh of things that sometimes
gets out of control and sometimes it
becomes so tight we are tightly coupled
with each other that that it's
inflexible and then sometimes it's so
unsecure that it's just flying all over
and
and and you kind of lose control right
over time so due to this tight coupling
every time a new application request
comes in an IT manager or infrastructure
need is like it's going to take X number
of days and X number not not days it's
probably months X amount of months and
there's much caused until we can
actually add this one tiny feature one
yes imagine when you have M&A activity
or you got acquired and you're like oh
great but now yeah how do you get
everything together exactly so what if
and what if is the theme today what if
there was a way to avoid this the
industry has converged to a set of open
source standards and and those standards
are are there to address this issue of
tight coupling her companies have found
that fully open modern approaches based
on containers offer a flexible approach
to dealing with infrastructure and tight
coupling kubernetes is an open source
platform for automate for automating
deployment of applications onto the
infrastructure and then it provides you
the portability an ability to change and
redeploy wherever you want to take that
application so it basically decouples
your underlying infrastructure from your
application so whatever the
infrastructure is if you decide to
change it tomorrow two years from now
ten years from now you're not locked
down into that infrastructure yeah
that's great avoiding lock-in and making
sure you're open flexible but also
secure exactly yes yeah and you're
you're basically a master of your own
destiny I would like to say just because
you made the decision that I don't want
to be tightly logged with either one
cloud provider or with my own premises
gyms or anything else I can just take
this application over and put it there
tomorrow so yeah and then when you work
with Google Google offers the advanced
fully managed environment for kubernetes
so that's the advantages you get with
working with Google container engine or
kubernetes engine because you basically
just leave all the management and
maintenance off your kubernetes clusters
on to Google and and you go build the
application yes yes Greek for helmsman
making sure you we actually do above and
beyond because we are able to adopt the
latest versions so those of you who
heard us say it's really easy with
kubernetes but you've been working on
your local machines and building a lot
of things yourselves yes try out the
Google communities engine exactly
actually you know what there is a github
page by Kelsey Hightower and he compares
the two together like you do kubernetes
on your own I think he calls it
kubernetes the hard way and then you do
the same thing on kubernetes engines and
then you see the comparison yeah how
it's day and night all right so we move
into the third stop in our journey which
is modernizing your application I have a
lot of conversations with leaders of
application development teams and they
all say pretty much the same thing that
you're seeing on the screen deployment
agility is what they want they want the
ability to get to the market time to
market for their features and
applications to be small and then they
want to do all of that without
compromising security yeah so one way
shape or form those are the things that
come out yes and this is again
traditional but you think of software
application firms but even from
designing hardware so yeah at the design
automation conference we had people
talking about maybe using Google Cloud
because it helps them with their global
teams globally distributed team
Zen really helps their team advance a
lot quicker and bit more manageable yeah
exactly
okay so that's where their challenges
are the development and application
development teams challenges are and
achieving these goals is obviously
difficult and is made more difficult
when you depend on legacy systems
because despite of whatever speed you
want to go with those legacy systems are
things that you need to understand and
and figure out how you're going to break
the barrier and move forward with your
speed exactly
hopefully it's documented and the person
who built that is still around but
sometimes that may not be there you but
you still depend on it okay no this is
exactly so you have a gap that that
between the need to deliver the customer
experience is quickly and fast and the
flexibility that's offered by your
legacy systems now how do you bridge
that gap what if we said that you you
can actually bridge that gap without
ripping any of your legacy systems it
can actually solve that by API
management which you see on this screen
Apogee is Google's API management
platform and it helps bridge that gap
between your legacy systems and the need
to deliver great customer experiences
quickly and fast get to get to market it
basically streamlines how you get your
how you access how you get access to the
api's how your developers get access to
the API is how you build your api's and
then how you monitor them make manage
them make them accessible to your
partners not just your internal
employees but your partner's your
customers in a secure fashion yes yes
and this is great for protecting your
legacy systems because as soon as you
have a partner or some customers
demanding access to key functionality
let's say for your new chatbot system
well you may have this legacy customer
system in the backend and it can't
necessarily handle the same scale as all
these new systems
yes Apogee can help throttle and protect
those resources yeah yes and then for
those that are actually that actually
don't have an interface to be accessed
by anybody like I want to say access
this mainframe system and it has got all
this great data but there's no API I
can't give it to anybody because I have
I have this huge amount of data and it's
locked and I have no access to no way to
get it out and that's where also Apogee
can help where you can
they can help you build a facade layer
on top of whatever this old system is
and make it look like it's a really nice
and shiny restful api that got that just
conned out yes excellent so yeah great
for legacy yeah in addition to new
systems standardizing on the api's and
developer portals yeah
the example that I want to bring up here
is the Chile implementation of the
National API based architecture and what
they did here was Chile had been
struggling and had tried to bring these
old healthcare and medical records
systems together and because they were
legacy in nature they had spent a lot of
time and money but didn't get the
results because the data was locked down
they couldn't get they couldn't get it
all together with they they used the API
management platform Apogee and what they
were able to do was was get api's in
front of every single every single
medical record system and now physicians
and people like normal users in Chile
like who were requiring
healthcare support were able to access
it and end the partners in the ecosystem
were able to access that information and
build better systems so it's great
go ahead read it in it it totally goes
with that with this whole healthcare
non-native did an old story yes that's
great for critical systems and
transformation at the public sector
level yeah very very compelling case
exactly and then the last step we are a
data in analytics this is the step where
we need to address that ml isn't
possible without proper data collection
so you can dream about ml but you won't
be able to execute anything if you don't
have a proper data strategy so in the
first three steps you'll be dealing with
data decisions like in migration and in
hybrid and then in modernizing you'll be
dealing with a lot of data related
decisions with with database their
databases which databases I need where
should I put my data what is it that I
actually collect and then how to store
so you can analyze the cost effectively
so when you make all these decisions
that's a better way to move into the
into the direction of ml nai yes so
acquiring and preparing the data so you
understand what's necessary and then it
also helps deal with some of these
machine learning fairness activities and
a lot of other research companies are
getting into now so a great way to
manage that
exactly and almost all analytics
literally meet with struggle with the
challenge of scaling their
infrastructure finding the critical
talent that can help with actually
working on the data and data and
analytics initiatives and then improving
cost and managing the growing
expectations from the from the business
leaders around getting valuable insights
from their data so many organizations
also recognize that artificial
intelligence will create competitive
advantages for them and some are already
starting to drive a IML initiatives
however they explore very quickly that
their current data or the current data
of their house may not be able to
provide the need needed speed at which
they would be successful at AI and mmm
so now the question is are you ready for
AI n mo if your company is not good at
analytics it's not ready for AI sorry to
say this but you need to be really good
at analytics first before you start
thinking about AI you need to know what
your data is you need to analyze it you
need to first be good at analytics
period if you're not doing that today
that's where you need to start so that's
that's your stepping stone into starting
to do mln AI
yeah so for my governance standpoint how
do you know you're good at analytics
well if you have different teams doing
calculations for the same metric and you
get different answers sometimes then
maybe you want to improve there and
there may be a process to go through
exactly yeah
we recently observed a company and
racing a big data database like Hadoop
or architecture to move through move to
words like AI ml but they found that
adding clusters to keep up with the data
volume and the query data requests
became increasingly difficult and
expensive yeah so there are things that
you keep learning over time as you start
to move into like move beyond that
analytics aspect of of things and data
in that I'm actually gonna skip this one
in the interest of time so Google offers
a fully managed petabytes kilo cost data
warehousing solution a platform where
you can ingest the data at terabyte
scale through an offering called cloud
pub/sub which is a messaging service has
the
to take requests from millions and
millions of different places and things
and devices and IOT things and just get
it on and get it inside your system
ingest it in your system and keep it as
messages and then there is the reliable
data pipeline which can take streaming
and batch imports at the at the same
time data flow and then as you move
along you need a data warehousing
platform and we have bigquery which is
petabyte scale data warehousing platform
I like to say it's SAS because you
really are just running queries and you
don't have to worry about whatever
amount of infrastructure is required
behind the scenes to actually run that
query and string and get the get the
results back and then when you're ready
for it you have cloud ml engine for
predictive insights and and then today a
data visualization you could visualize
data within Google Data studio 3 for
free or if you have a data visualization
platform of your choice we have
connectors from bigquery that can just
connect the data into your visualization
platform as well so that's the data
platform built we that we've built that
we really believe in petabyte scale data
platform that is low cost and server
less so most of our products in that
category or server less so you don't
have to worry about the infrastructure
all right and so we went through a lot
so let's summarize this very quickly
we've walked through migration of your
legacy system into Google cloud using
professional services cloud start cloud
sprint may be called secure and then and
and some tools like hardened your value
strata transfer appliance and once you
are migrated or / migrated partly you're
in
hybrid and multi-cloud scenario where
your where your where you want to make
sure you build your applications in a
containerized fashion so you can take
them anywhere and you're not logged down
and then moving into modernizing your
applications using Apogee API management
where you could unlock that potential of
your old mainframe data or old data
that's sitting somewhere that's not
accessible you use Apogee API management
platform to build that facade layer and
make it accessible to other developers
partners that can unlock that potential
and then you move into data and
analytics and machine learning and we
talked about Google's petabyte scale
surrealist data management platform for
that yes and so for those who are just
trying to get started and you're
responsible for the budget we can
definitely help custom engineers
professors and our partners to do TCO
analysis using additional tools so
there's a lot to learn and we wish you
good luck and if you would like to get
in touch with us reach out to either
your customer team or go on to
cloud.google.com and you will find all
the resources there as well great thank
you and stay tuned for a live Q&A in
less than an it will be back
welcome back and now we'll get started
with a live Q&A thanks a lot for your
questions so first our executives think
that cloud is not secure for our systems
we deal with financial services and all
the data is very confidential how would
you help me make an argument for cloud
that's an interesting question one that
we get very often the way I would say
that is cloud is actually much more
secure than your physical data centers
exactly well yeah our cloud and the
reason I say that is based on couple of
different things when we when we store
your data it's encrypted at rest and in
motion you have the choice to bring your
own keys you have the choice to have
Google managing your keys and so however
strong your policies around keys are we
can we can totally accommodate that but
even if you don't we are encrypting your
data at rest and in motion whenever it
is but then the group within the Google
cloud platform and then second we are
actually not just and the reason I said
Google Cloud Data Centers and when you
store data in Google cloud it's much
more secure is because you would take
your data and imagine this is this is
your data actually imagine this is your
data and you put it and you put it in in
your data center physical location and
you encrypted fine it's probably going
to be secure until somebody hits your
data center and try to access it but if
it is in Google Cloud we've actually
shredded that data into multiple
different pieces and and those pieces
are encrypted individually and then they
are shipped into different data center
locations and then they are stored there
so even if somebody was able
to access or hack one of our data
centers and get that one piece it's I
highly doubt that somebody's able to
access our all of our data centers and
put all of that data together from the
shredded pieces and make it back into
that one piece and be able to decrypt it
it's highly I find it highly improbable
so that's why I say it's much google
cloud is much more secure and yeah I
would if you if you need more
information we have white papers on how
we encrypt data and what our strategy
around data encryption is and what are
your different options so please do
check that out as well yes and as
customer engineers I know we love giving
security briefings to our customers
exactly yeah you if you feel like you
would like somebody from our team to
come in and do a briefing for your
executives one of our team members would
be happy to do that as well great next
we have a few legacy systems payroll and
ear PR the main systems we have designed
these internally and we are having to
spend a lot of money maintaining them
over the years how can cloud help so
there are a couple of different options
here I think I'll say three to touch on
different and there could be more a
combination of the ones that I talked
about one is you could just migrate your
entire ERP system into cloud obviously a
huge undertaking but that could be one
option the other is you basically do
part part migration bring parts of your
system into cloud and then the third um
which in some cases works out is the SAS
offering right you if you if you are not
using all the systems or all the
features and functionalities of your
legacy system or you were looking for
something where you're like I don't have
the people to maintain this old system I
would rather you know pay a subscription
based model you could
she also choose a sass pay service for
payroll or ERP and just not have to
worry about maintaining it yes yes so
that's great and then next uh what is
the benefit of a multi cloud or hybrid
cloud strategy we talked a little bit
about this which is containers right so
when you when you think about multi
cloud or hybrid cloud you're basically
in the arena where you're thinking or
you've you've been on premise for a long
time or you've been in another cloud for
a long time and you're thinking I can't
reap the benefits of every single thing
that's out there
and I want to actually take advantage of
that every single cloud has different
strengths if I talk about Google cloud
we talked about container and kubernetes
engine we are the best at offering you a
managed kubernetes offering so if you
were to do something if you were to deal
with kubernetes and containers you would
probably look to us and then similarly
taking an example of bigquery if you
want to just run queries on petabyte
storage space and not have to worry
about the thousands of servers that you
need to actually run that query you
probably look to Google and so the
reason I give these examples you every
single cloud has their own advantages so
the customers that we speak with who
want to go multi-cloud want to read the
benefits of all the different cloud
providers have to offer and don't want
to be logged down so that is why moving
towards containers is an approach that
keeps you not logged down into one
particular doctor wider and keeps you
open for all the possibilities that that
your business might open up later yes
that's great Google has their really big
open philosophy and also as you see with
our commitment to open source again we
have a great idea like kubernetes we
make it available
now other cloud providers able to
interoperate thank you and so no legacy
ERP systems are running on physical
servers with San attached
how can one cross-check the performance
before a migrating to cloud you want to
shake back yes
okay because I worked with a lot of
different legacy systems and also don't
work as a middleware architects this
comes up a lot but you first need to
think about the requirements of your
particular ERP system so most of the
time you don't necessarily have
limitations from a license standpoint
but from the Google cloud platform
perspective we offer several different
options for compute and storage
including one of our recently released
beta offerings for a cloud file store so
in addition to SSD and our this we do
you have various storage options but I
think might be even more interesting is
if you are an s AP customer go to the
Google cloud launcher in the cloud and
console cloud that google.com search for
s IP and then do a click to deploy for
for s AP and then test the performance
check the versioning to see if it
matches and then test the performance so
the best way for you to check is to do a
proof of concept and we make it very
simple again you can deploy s ap with a
couple of clicks I think probably less
than five clicks so try that and then
let us know all right awesome great so
stay tuned for the next session how G
suite customers use the new hangouts
hangouts meet hardware and this kit lets
you set up a really affordable reliable
video conferencing at scale I said I
like having this one button
[Laughter]
you